apple as always has done a really great
job on usability but guess what there's
no free time search there's no ability
to counter propose there's no ability to
delegate a meeting to somebody else I
can't even send comments in if I accept
a meeting
there's there's nothing it's Yes No
Maybe
so really great interface but because
they've narrowed the scope so much of
what they're going to actually try to
accomplish well of course if I was
building a simple calendar interface it
looked pretty hot right now too but if
I'm trying to build one that does
everything you know it's more
complicated which uh which brings me to
another Point uh and actually I think it
brings in a few subjects at the same
time you've got privacy of information
what you're willing to share with other
people and so on you've got you know if
you look at
the Notes Calendar you look at
Outlook calendar you look at you know
all these different calendars you take
out the logo they pretty much all look
the same you know you know a seven day
Grid or depending on the visualization
on a day or a week or yeah pretty much
the look is the same you think
and that grid View
I mean before people had day planners so
it wasn't really a grid view but you
know it was day planners and you had
Monday yeah but then when we went uh on
the PC we started to have the grid View
um and it hasn't really evolved yet
do you think that's going to evolve do
you think people are willing to evolve
and if so how do you think that will
evolve there's a lot of PC metaphors
that are still stuck in some past
experience and I I often think
kind of one of the you know spare
daydreaming things that I I sit there
and think about if we didn't have this
installed base what would we do
differently I mean you can you could do
that about anything my favorite one is
if we didn't have stop lights today red
yellow green simple lights on a pole
what would if in 2010 if you had a bunch
of Traffic Engineers try to come up with
a traffic control signal for an
intersection would they come up with
three little lights on a post
no no way so but that's what we have
right that's what we have in 2010 we're
stuck with it because you're never going
to teach the whole world some different
metaphor right and you know even in 2010
the metaphor of a folder within your
mail or the icon is save and most
applications still looks like a floppy
disk and I haven't seen a physical
floppy disk in at least you know 10
years right so we get stuck in these
metaphors of the past because of the
curse of the install base and that's no
offense to anybody's an end user but
when you've trained millions of people
to do something teaching them to do it a
different ways is really a challenge so
again as slick as an iPad or a
Blackberry or whatever is today in 2010
they've still stuck with the metaphors
that Computing industry invented 10 or
20 years ago it will take some major
inflection activity to get people
comfortable doing it some other way and
I think activity based may be the way to
do that but we've been talking about
that now what do you mean by activity
like so I'm more focused done this
project and this thing that I want to
work on then some time slot and some
email that somebody sent me and we but
we've been talking about that concept
within our research team for six years
now some of it's in our product today
but we still can't get to a metaphor
that's different it still ties to the
existing tools and systems
it could be that there's a better way
out there and our researchers have some
really good ideas but even when I see
them do new research projects they still
start with a grid and
so I think that it's going to be some
major inflection event maybe it's around
location services maybe it's around some
Cloud thing that we don't know of yet
um that you think the mobile can play a
role I think mobile is probably the key
there right because mobile is where the
Innovations happening right now faster
than I can write software
can write I can see mobile devices with
six month lifespan coming out with new
interfaces and new capabilities
so
if that's the place where it will happen
you know consumer adoption happens there
as well and that's the thing driving a
lot of I.T is the end user can go buy
their own mobile device in most
companies
so I can choose to adopt an iPhone I can
choose to adopt a Blackberry I can
choose to adopt a Nokia nobody's
choosing to adopt Windows mobile but
anyway sorry
um
but as an end user if I'm making that
choice I'm making that choice based on
oh Android has these really great
features but oh by the way Android
doesn't have a calendar that's built
into the operating system yet even in
Froyo 2.2 they have some sort of vague
data glance thing and personal calendar
but they don't have an Enterprise
calendar function but
so now it's up to us as a veteran to go
fill that hole right so every device is
doing things different and now that more
of them have an app store model where a
user can put their own stuff on there
users will adopt what makes sense to
them I don't like the way that Twitter
looks so I'll go to flipbook I don't you
know I'm not really excited about you
know the Facebook app as it's installed
I'm going to go to some different UI
right I could use the browser for half
these things but the apps have actually
made it much more interesting or usable
right the New York Times publish is a
perfectly good website but they have an
app on there that takes that website and
formats it specifically for the iPad so
I'm using that right
so I think that users will prod it along
but I don't know what the thing is that
they're going to latch onto have you
tried Flipboard by the way yeah I mean
what do you think I think it's great
it's awesome man I mean it's the same
information that we're used to seeing
every day is just displayed differently
and people are like no I never knew have
that information well the thing that
they did that's smart is they go one
level down on the links yeah right
because half those links that you see in
a Twitter stream you'd probably never
click on but all of a sudden you're
reading the article or the summary of
the article you go oh that's pretty
interesting